so Aria you are a transgender kosher
conservative Jew and a bioengineer
scientist how do you exist well it's
been a struggle I've had to fight to
exist actually so you grew up religious
a reform you grew up or reformed you
which to the to the lay people watching
at home and grew up listening to techno
how did you make a transition from
reform to conservative well in college I
actually started going to acidic
synagogue on the weekends really just to
find out more about myself and about
Jewish mysticism because I had some
question and obviously was questioning
more than I thought why'd you leave
Reform Judaism go towards conservative
judaism wouldn't reform have been more
accepting and loving toward escalation
especially in my family none of my
family members are as conservative as i
am that's crazy so I go home and I'm
like no mom I'm not eating pork why do
you guys do this to me and then they
complain of stomachaches
you said that is such a Jewish right and
then they complained of stomachache like
well would you say you eat Morlocks as a
man or a woman that never changed that's
always kind of the study because
everything what is your perspective on
homosexuality well it's changed actually
I was actually very homophobic before
and only had relationships with women as
a man for a long time and recently as my
body has changed a lot I've all of my
assumptions have been challenged and I
think my attraction has also been
changed or affected by the transition
orientation and gender identity or
separate my mom does not agree with that
your mom thinks what you're gay she
wishes I was gay probably you were tired
of the testosterone that was
biologically pumping through your body
and what did you choose and the hair I
mean I had a huge hair issue you're a
Jew I mean that's not a gender thing but
you want to show you if like how bad it
could have been shed you can feel free
yeah I mean I don't know hates me very
scared of this I would think everybody
was staring at my like nude our forearms
or something but when I wore a small
faced watch it was one of the first
things that I did
when the crosstrack feminine things that
you did and what was that feeling like
when you first did that guilty
you thought I was a dude it was a
thrilling of course
so was guilt and thrill yeah and I would
go back every day and crossdress and it
would be this repeating cycle until I
decided I didn't want to just cross
dress are you a scientist first or a Jew
first or a transwoman first what's the
most important identity marker for you a
musician music I think I was available
what kind of music do you marry honest
and I like EDM production are you like
techno yeah told you was about techno
guys why not be in a more funky you know
liberal strain of Judaism that would
automatically accept your gender
identity doesn't appeal to me I really
want something that's deep and connected
to God and an inspiring way that reminds
me of the ancient times and really what
a lot of history has been leading to of
course like a lot of Jews want the
Messiah to come Moshe you know all about
that I'm sure I mean I'm thinking on
might be that person exactly on show on
Comedy Central
there's nothing holding me back from
revealing myself exactly just take off
his glasses and then BOOM wait what I
got to take off the glasses this is what
the Jewish Messiah would look like it's
not like I'm here oh I'll get to you
that's what he'd say thank you for
coming and now that we figured out how
you exist I'm glad that you exist thank
you so much
[Music]
[Applause]